my politics hasn't changed they've
changed when you say whoa
letting three-year-olds decide what
gender they are choose wisely you're
right you haven't changed but the
liberals have but you still vote for
people who usher this stuff in so what
are the last things that make someone
like bill maher say he's a liberal still
still believe in big government programs
in affirmative action one black coming
up government handout or please there's
just no evidence that any of that stuff
works read any thomas soul book facts
they believe that conservatives are
backwards religious believers but
societies cannot work without something
that is bigger than themselves
consequences of that was going to be
bloody catastrophe because everything
was going to fall and he predicted the
rise of communism for example and the
deaths of tens of millions of people in
the aftermath of the death of god the
first time ever god stand back she's
gonna blow who believes more in your
liberal beliefs at this point if you
really want to stop wokeness then you
got to get to the end of the road man